hello and welcome to this video playing
game guys guys are and I'm kind of
surprised that sir GM account that i
have nope games played against
absolutely not a single game Salvador
Alonso okay so um yo what to do play the
queen bee three line here this is the
main line that I I don't know that well
to be honest interesting huh I would
like to go before you but I wonder if
some b5 is coming then maybe maybe I
just I should go back first gen and now
he for whom he might take on b3 I mean
but let's still if it's play that
shouldn't be shouldn't be bad
okay doesn't want to take but do I play
a Bishop f4 I guess is the most logical
looking square for the bishop and so que
no it takes it I interesting yeah but
what we should each for ya I would like
to gain the bishop pair so I try that he
can still go Bishop h5 this is certainly
possible no he wants to do this okay
I'll grab the bishop pair and and now
takes I can just take it you know let's
do that and here
it looks like maybe a slight advantage
for white maybe I cannot play rook the
eighth for example which is helpful ok
so the Tiki five-night x f4 I mean he
doesn't have many squares let's see
let's to go to g4 I just got the check
Jack I got that bloody check and so this
tactic is actually saving black
otherwise it would be in big trouble
already yeah this is of course working
hmmmm that was very stupid again I
should have at least looked at this for
for a moment and not just allow that
allow that stuff
here quite unnecessary could have
prepared that without any particular
problem and now what's rooty to maybe I
have a book t2
hmm rocky too low key quickly 293 I can
I go Kim Ji Won very weird Jack yeah I
basically have to check or not if i go
to f2 and 92 m and if i go here my jiju
i cannot wrap it so after I have to take
this
yeah I was thinking maybe counter
ticking f7 as an idea but he prevented
that very nicely
look T 1 king e 2 is not that clear Roxy
to Ascot though I made mad the ship d7
maybe I can still play Bishop d7 this
one here can i hit 196 vertical is mate
mate is not good to allow time morning
cannot too much about it
ruge f7 maybe roecastle threatening
decent I could move anyplace it very
very well here yeah I'm just I'm just
just a very stupid player sometimes
allowing this was very very very very
nice very signs yeah this is just very
naive and then therefore I just didn't
look at Bishop c5 not not at all now
it's got 95 coming it's interesting
actually that here here he has this move
which is good for black very nice
decision took
yeah it's good for black I mean why I
cannot really rescues my pieces here and
now we know you can play that yeah that
is very this is just giant work it just
doesn't work rook t3 is better and let's
still kind of okay check yeah this is I
think you played well I mean I have some
ideas but ok yeah I'd Bishop to g5
interesting he cannot take it that's
funny that's me I'd so funny made check
checkmate so he can go here and it looks
looks nice they have it I don't have
much you can always play kind of similar
to the game and I have nothing yeah and
this is a very well defended no yeah
just just not a good game just not a
good game they are probably okay
probably here I don't have much 95 is
good computer wants to play like this
and assesses this is equal yeah probably
probably i get b 7 and things straight
down yeah very naive play by me taking
only five okay thanks for watching